and I'm joined now by NATO
secretary-general Jens Stoltenberg and
you said in your speech very interesting
that after brexit 80% of NATO's budget
will be borne by non-european members in
other words the European countries are
very dependent in particular on Turkey
and the u.s. the two biggest players are
the Europeans really stepping up to the
plate they say they're doing more but is
it enough European allies are now
stepping up and I welcome the efforts of
the European Union to strengthen their
defence cooperation that is important
and it's also very good at European
allies among them Germany are now
investing more in defense but this is
not an alternative to NATO this is
something that is going to complement
NATO and strengths need to buy strength
in the European pillar within NATO
because 80% of NATO's defence
expenditure will come from non EU NATO
allies there is no way we can deal
ink.you security or security for
European allies from NATO and the North
Atlantic bond now two of those non
European countries currently stand on
opposite sides of a conflict and I'm
referring of course to Turkey and the US
you mentioned this as well in your
remarks Turkey attacking the Kurds in
northern Syria Kurds who were trained
and were and cooperated with by the
United States how concerned are you
about this conflict between two NATO
member countries we are concerned about
the situation in Syria where hundreds of
thousands of civilians have been killed
and millions have been forced to flee
and the way we have a very difficult
situation then Turkey and the United
States and Germany and all NATO allies
have worked together in the global
coalition to defeat Isis so we have
worked together and achieved a lot the
challenge now is of course what we see
in northern Syria
they're NATO's not present on the ground
in northern Syria the United States is
and Turkey is I welcome that they have
guided contact I know that secretary
mattis met with his his counterpart the
Turkish defense minister during the NATO
defense ministerial and also that
secretary Tillerson
met in Ankara so the important thing is
to make sure that Turkey and all these
dates have dialed contact and they have
and then Turkey also briefed all NATO
allies Turkey has some legitimate
security concerns they have suffered
mortised attacks than any other NATO
ally but they have to respond in a
proportionate at an unmeasured way you
also mentioned your strong concern about
North Korea and the threat of nuclear
confrontation and you called for maximum
pressure to be put on North Korea
including by European countries the fact
is North Korea is really only interested
in the United States what more can be
done
what is that maximum pressure you called
for we need strong economic sanctions
and the United States is member of the
Security Council as is all the NATO
allies and the Russia and China and we
need them to agree on effective economic
sanctions and I welcome the fact that
the UN Security Council actually agreed
to increase the economic sanctions and
also the fact that we see that the
sanctions are now to a larger extent
implemented which means that the
sanctions have an impact on North Korea
the alternative to her maximum pressure
with political means diplomatic means
and economic sanctions is to either use
military force that will be really
dangerous
or to do nothing which will also be
dangerous so the only viable Etana
alternative is to continue to work for a
peaceful negotiated solution but for
North Korea to accept that we need to be
pressure on them and that's exactly what
we are doing at times president Trump
and even some other members of his
administration have indicated that a
resort to force might be an option is
that an option for you the United States
supports the efforts to find a political
solution and the United States is key in
implementing and agreeing the economic
sanctions in the UN Security Council at
the same time of course the United
States has the right to defend itself if
it is attacked this is a deterrence and
the Tarrance is the way NATO has
responded to threats from ballistic
missiles for decades that was the way
with the deterred the Soviet Union
during the Cold War and that's in fact
the same we do today
sending a clear message that we have the
resolve and the capability and the
capabilities to respond if we are
attacked
thank you very much Secretary General
Stoltenberg